i am a genie we might not be able to
grant you three wishes like the genie
but we're pretty sure
this video is about to make all your
dreams come true can you make me a
princess
welcome back the things fans it's time
for you to get ready to head into a
whole new world
disney has the super important job of
making sure their live action remakes
come with just as much 90s nostalgia as
their animated versions
and when it comes to the aladdin remake
we can see just how hard they work to
make it perfect by taking a peek behind
the curtain
but they couldn't do it without having
all the fun of course in this video
we're taking you behind the cameras with
bloopers deleted scenes and everything
in between
to show you just how they kept that
nostalgic magic alive
little monkey with the lamp trick this
first deleted scene features acrobat's
finest street rat his pet monkey and of
course the lovely
dahlia we all know the iconic story
about aladdin and jasmine's first
meeting
he saved her after she accidentally
steals from a street merchant to feed
poor children
robin hood is that you but this live
action has been holding back an adorable
love at first sight moment between the
two that never made the final cut
flower petals and all and then they
proceeded to quite literally run for
their lives
how romantic oh
dear sorry speaking of running for their
lives
what would an intense disney chase be
without a good musical number
aladdin's performance of one jump ahead
was nothing short of perfect but that
perfection came with a lot of movie
magic
it's just unrealistic to think that a
street cart would be perfectly placed to
carry you to your destination or that
aladdin would make
every humanly impossible jump well let's
just say that a lot of rope was involved
and we're betting a lot of takes also
shout out to mina masood for absolutely
killing the number though
there are stairs you know
[Music]
with two main characters played by
actors like mina and naomi scott
there's no doubt they had a blast
filming together their chemistry was
iconic both on
and off camera and these adorable behind
the scenes moments of the two will make
your heart skip a beat
convince us that they're not literally
aladdin and jasmine in real life
not to mention the adorable pictures the
two of them shared while filming on set
do you have a favorite moment between
these two co-stars
[Music]
get off although there was plenty of
skepticism before the live action was
released over whether or not will smith
could pull off being the genie
it's safe to say his character ended up
being a huge hit
how could we doubt that the fresh prince
wouldn't step into that role with
everything he had
while he was in a lot of the movie they
couldn't fit all of his appearances into
the 90 minutes
that's what deleted scenes are for and
this one happens right after aladdin
made a fool of himself
when offering gifts to princess jasmine
who doesn't love fireworks
fireworks i like fireworks if you've
watched aladdin you know that while the
idea of three wishes from a magical
genie sounds pretty ideal they could
have terrible consequences
which is why the genie makes sure
aladdin knows exactly how to make a
proper wish before he touches the lamp
but in this deleted scene the genie
takes his warning a step further and
even tells aladdin's stories of his past
masters
course haid wish to be irresistible to
all women
if you've watched will smith in action
you know that he can't go 10 minutes
without making an entire room burst into
laughter
oh the genie is on fire so there's no
doubt being on set with this
world-renowned celebrity was anything
short of absolutely
hilarious and these behind-the-scenes
moments with will are all the proof we
need
how did they even get through filming a
serious scene with him it's a big snake
it's a scary snake a lot of us grew up
watching disney hoping one day to live
out our own fairy tales
true love magic and royalty were what we
dreamed of and the a whole new world
scene was literally the definition of
everything disney
imagine being whisked away on a magic
carpet but while we'd all love to
pretend that that could actually happen
we're here to burst your bubble and to
show you just how unmagical the filming
for the live-action version
actually was well at least we got
adorable behind-the-scenes moments of
mina and naomi vlogging together
hey hey girl look how beautiful she
looks
we definitely wouldn't have had the
bantering relationship between aladdin
and the genie on screen if there wasn't
a huge bromance off screen
yep we're talking about mina and will if
you thought mina and naomi were adorable
off screen
wait until you see some of the behind
the scenes antics these two actors got
into
nina might claim that he's so hard to
work with this is ridiculous but we'd
wager
it's actually the exact opposite what do
you guys think of a full-length movie
just of their bloopers
we need it asap he's been amazing i mean
seriously the best
cast mate i could ask for speaking of
off-camera mina well
he's hilarious will definitely wasn't
the only comedian on set during their
months of filming
whether it was throwing out random peace
signs modeling aladdin's outfit
or ruining takes by walking through them
when he wasn't supposed to
he looks like he would be fun to work
with what actor out of the cast would
you want to work with the most
this is max rad he's about to get he's
about to get mad at me
this next scene we're going to talk
about took a lot of work not just from
the main cast but from literally
hundreds of people
it's probably the most showy scene of
the movie and if you take a look at the
behind the scenes of it it definitely
wasn't easy to create
it's the genies parade into the castle
singing prince ali
fabulousy alia babwa of course the cgi
team
also had a lot of work to do take a look
just as much
a pleasure for me your highness sir
sometimes when you're on set things just
don't go as planned and that applies to
everyone and everything
if every take of a movie went perfectly
it wouldn't take months of filming to
get the film done
whether it's props not cooperating or
actors just having a human moment
we can't all be ninjas in real life
mistakes happen
but that doesn't mean those mistakes
can't be hilarious in fact the aladdin
live action has some pretty hilarious
bloopers
let's just say they really know how to
make you fall for them
um oh here
um of course jasmine couldn't just
return to the palace grounds and pretend
that nothing had happened during her
rendezvous in agrabah
in this deleted scene the princess
pleads with her father to see what she
does when it comes to their people and
maybe get rid of jafar once and for all
she's a strong independent princess with
an actual pet tiger and no one
not even a villain is going to stop her
it may have taken a while for him to
come around but she got her way in the
end
the people were threatened by your
soldiers not by criminals
speaking of jafar this deleted scene
really brings out his true character
if you weren't sure how far jafar would
actually go to one day rule agrabah
this scene will sure tell you he'll go
to any lengths in order to get his hands
on the genie lamp and his sidekick iago
is right there on his shoulder ready to
help him every step of the way
even if it means turning to the sands of
time i need
real power i need the land speaking of
iago
pets are a huge part of aladdin we have
iago abu and raja as main characters
throughout the film
and while this may be a live-action
version of the film we hate to break it
to you but the animals are still very
much cgi
which means during filming they're not
actually next to the actors
well things can get a bit awkward on set
when there's a monologue and the actors
find themselves speaking to a stuffed
animal
instead russia
ah prince anders if only you'd come to
woo the princess before she met aladdin
we're sure if his goofiness hadn't
impressed her his canon in this deleted
scene might have
bombs away he may not have impressed
jasmine but he sure did impress the
studio
disney recently announced that they have
a prince anders spin-off currently at
the work
we can't wait to see where this spin-off
takes him and his canon
how do you feel about disney's
announcement you
naughty girls you lied of course at the
end of the day
a movie is only as good as its cast and
this behind the scenes moment of will
wrapping on set
shows you just how much love was between
both the cast and crew
we can't be anything but grateful that
disney managed to put together such an
amazing team to bring us some more
disney magic
we're sweating just thinking about how
much time and effort went into making
this film disney ready kudos to mina
naomi and will for pulling off some of
the biggest disney characters ever while
still managing to keep the fun behind
the scenes alive
it's like a freaking student film
what was your favorite behind the scenes
moment do you think they should have
kept in any deleted scenes
let us know in the comment section below
don't forget to give this video a thumbs
up
hit that subscribe button and we'll see
you next time